ja ich begrüße die heutige sitzung heute
uns sehr viel vorgenommen sie erinnern
sich wir hatten das letzte mal noch mal
ganz kurz plattform gemacht werden
wiederholt hier hatten die vorzüge die
nachteile der korrespondenz theorie und
der kohärenz theorie diskutiert haben
dann platt und abgehakt sind
weitergegangen
augustinus haben noch was gelesen von
anselm von canterbury und haben es dann
nicht mehr ganz geschafft bis zum thomas
von aquin und das wollen wir also heute
nachholen aber ganz zu beginn möchte ich
noch die leitfragen der heutigen sitzung
hier an die tafel werfen also wir haben
die frage welche wahrheit theorie thomas
von aquin vertritt immer vor dem
hintergrund der zwei möglichkeiten
corinths theorie oder korrespondenz
theorie wir haben gesagt es könnte auch
noch so etwas geben wie evidenz theorie
oder was auch noch ein kandidat ist ist
die sogenannte theorie die auf konsens
passiert also die konsens theorie der
wahrheit aber da wird ihn natürlich
sofort der einwand kommen damit dass
alle übereinstimmen einer sache heißt
nicht dass die sache war ist also wenn
über den satz die behauptung p
90 prozent aller münchner der meinung
sind dass die richtig ist der satz dass
münchen an der isar liegt
und 90 das glauben oder 99 oder 99 9999
wie auch immer man heißt das nicht dass
der satz war ist als die consense
theorie der wahrheit die ist sehr
problematisch und die wird auch in bei
den theoretikern die wir klagen nicht
vertreten
und dann wollen wir noch die frage
stellen wie wahrheit und methode bei
deka zusammenhängen also ich vertrete
die these dass beide parteien ganz neues
verständnis der wahrheit und des
verhältnisses der wahl zum zugelegt
ansetzt ganz anders als bei platow noch
ist anders als es im mittelalterlichen
mittelalter ist das wollen wir schauen
wie verändert sich das wahrheit'
verständnis des wahrheit' verhältnis von
subjekt
erkenntnis zügig und objekt und wahrheit
beratung hat mir letzten sitzung noch
einmal ausführlich besprochen
ganz wichtig bei platon hier dieses
dreieck ja also oben die idee des guten
die hält alles zusammen darunter die
ideen denen die idee des guten die
einheit gibt man könnte auch sagen die
karenz gibt und dann ganz unten in der
st innenwelt die abbilder die wir
erkennen können wo sie die frage nach
der korrespondenz unserer auffassung
stellt und die korrespondenz wird eben
geleistet durch die karenz der ideen
durch die vermittelnde funktion der idee
des guten also man kann sagen wie platon
erfährt beide dimensionen corinths
theorie und korrespondenz theorie
zusammen erlöst in seinem dreieck wie
wir es an gezeichnet hatten die probleme
beide theorien könnte man sagen man kann
das natürlich auch genau verfolgen wie
es im bezahlten aussieht deswegen
überspringe ich den und kommen jetzt
ganz kurz zu aristoteles den ich ihnen
noch nach schieben möchte weil sich
viele der mittelalterlichen denker auf
ihnen beziehen und aristoteles wird in
der mittelalterlichen debatte immer nur
der philosoph genannt wo viel los
griechische wort der kann sich das ein
bisschen so vorstellen die im deutschen
wenn sie sagen das ist die expertin
oder es ist der neue star wenn sie das
der betonen das ist der philosoph
schlechthin
das ist der angesagte song dass der song
des jahres
so ein bisschen diese richtung und was
sagt der aristoteles wer von ihnen
möchten wir lesen bitte
den höchsten versuchen dass wir damit
nicht daran hängen dicht
vielen dank
also was war ein wahrheit' verständnis
die tcm aristoteles ihr zugrunde wenn
sie mal überlegen welche theorien der
wahrheit wir bisher kennen gelernt
hatten
würden sie sagen dass es ihr nicole renz
theorie ist oder ihre korrespondenz
theorie
genau also die wirklichkeit die
tatsachen könnte man auch sagen richten
sich nicht nach unserer meinung unsere
meinungen oder unsere setzte das was wir
in die vp bringen dass etwas so und so
ist die position die müssen sich nach
der wahrheit richten die werden an dem
war an der tanne an der realität
gemessen
könnte man sagen dass das so eine
formulierung der korrespondenz theorie
ist tatsächlich sagen viele dass
aristoteles der erste ist ja die
korrespondenz theorie der wahrheit zu
definiert oder oder angegeben hat das
wollte ich nur noch kurz vorweg schicken
es findet sich bei annas tod ist jetzt
nicht so viel zur wahrheit aber das ist
doch ein zentrales zitat bei diesen
gelegenheiten wir noch einmal auf die
problematik hinweisen die jede
korrespondenz theorie hat die
korrespondenz theorie erscheint zunächst
mal plausibler zu sein als eine bloße
kohärenz theorie aber weil sie haben ja
bei einer korrespondenz theorie immer
den bezug zur wirklichkeit zu den
tatsachen
aber jetzt überlegen sie mal wir hatten
ja gesagt auch die korrespondenz theorie
es problematisch jetzt überlegen sie mal
was sagen sie denn eigentlich wenn sie
sagen wahrheit ist die übereinstimmung
und versetzte unserer meinung unseres
denkens mit den tatsachen
was haben sie denn eigentlich dann
gemacht argumentation slogan
ja
ja ich denke das geht in die richtige
richtung da ist genau genau als oder
anders formuliert sie noch genauer ein
zirkel genau also indem man man will
wahrheit bestimmen sagt das ist eine
übereinstimmung aber in dem der indem
man sagt das ist eine übereinstimmung
mit der wirklichkeit und den tatsachen
hat man eigentlich schon wahrheit'
begriff zugrunde gelegt weil was
wirklich ist was tatsächlich ist ist
tatsächlich als ist war der fall also
die frage ist immer begierig ein
zirkelschluss oder eine tautologie oder
was auch immer
wenn wir nicht korrespondenz theorie so
formulieren dass es eine übereinstimmung
mit der welt wie sie wirklich ist mit
der wahren welt ist ja aber das wollten
wir gerade wissen was wahr ist also das
ist so ein bisschen das problem dass man
sagen könnte eine korrespondenz
theoretische bestimmung der wahrheit
definition der wahrheit wenn überhaupt
wahrheit definieren kann
die c't auto logisch oder ist
zirkulieren
könnte es noch ein bisschen ausführen
also
ja
also das wäre von augustin ist an eine
sehr starke prämisse
das ist ja nicht der fall muss muss ja
nicht der fall sein das sei und wahrheit
korrigieren zusammengehen sie sehen dann
kommt er in große schwierigkeiten ein
weiteres problem der korrespondenz
theorie erinnern sie sich noch weiß
jemand von ihnen noch was noch ein
problem der korrespondenz theorie der
wahrheit war das haben wir einmal so ein
bisschen das problem das ist zirkular i
tät aber denken sie noch mal nach und
lässt die sitzung
wenn sie jetzt nicht mehr auf die seite
der wirklichkeit schauen also das
erkenntnis objekt steht in einer
relation zu
das ist also eine relation da steht in
korrespondenz zur wirklichkeit was
setzen wir verein ja ja
ja wobei man das jetzt voraussetzt dass
es sich angleichen könnte als man sagt
wahrheit ist ein gelingen dass das
gelingen eines prozesses des
angemessenen bezugs zur wirklichkeit
also wahrheit hat dieses angemessene
schon drinnen natürlich kann es dann
auch die abweichung geben aber es wäre
gerade falschheit als man geht davon aus
das ist erst mal gelingt dass ich an
gleich und schreibt mir in wirklichkeit
tatsachen möglichkeit
was kann ich hier noch einsetzen für
ferrari subjekt aber was noch man sagt
wenn ich in der korrespondenz theorie
wahrheit ist die übereinstimmung des
objekts mit der welt sind würde man
sagen er verstand oder denken vielleicht
denken denken aber schon richtig dass es
auch das objekt seite liegt denken ja
aber wie kann sich jetzt das denken
wieder schön wie kann das denken
übereinstimmen in der wirklichkeit wie
soll man sich das denken dass das denken
irgendwie adäquat ist korrespondierte
wirklichkeit denken in wirklichkeit sind
doch zwei verschiedene dinge könnten uns
sagt
so so ja wobei man ja nichts sagt es
geht schon vom denken zur wirklichkeit
aber um dieses problem zu lösen müsste
man ihm genau das machen was sie sagen
nämlich eine doppelspitze sagen
wirklichkeit und denken hängt untrennbar
miteinander zusammen
sie sind jetzt endlich irgendwie in
einer auf einer auf einer abstrakten
ebene in einer abstrakten struktur
struktur analogie storkow analog das ist
dann aber wiederum das sehr starke
vermisse die man spezialitäten die man
setzt warum sollte denn die wirklichkeit
mit unserem denken übereinstimmt eine
mögliche antwort hatten wir das letzte
mal gegeben ändern sich nachdenken
evolutionstheorie was könnte man aus
evolutionstheorie ethischen perspektive
sagen warum könnten aus dieser sicht
denken und wirklichkeit irgendwie analog
sei genau genau also die wirklichkeit
bringt uns hervor
damit bringt sie auch die wirklichkeit
wenn man es mal so reden möchte damit
bringt sie auch unser denken hervor und
weil unser denken jetzt endlich aus der
wirklichkeit aus der natur oder was auch
immer stammt ist es mit ihm verwandt die
wissen was könnte man sagen ja aber was
könnte man dagegen argumentieren gegen
die evolutionstheorie tische wahrheit'
theorie oder evolutionäre wahrheit'
theorie das könnte man dagegen einwenden
ja
genau könnte sagen ja wir sind eben
angepasst hier auf eine skala auf eine
dimension von ich sag mal 1 mm oder
physikalisch vielleicht zehn hoch minus
drei tausendstel millimeter und
vielleicht ich weiß nicht 10 hoch 5 und
wieso also diesem spektrum funktioniert
unsere kenntnis wenn wir in die ebene
der quanten gehen verstehen wir
plötzlich nichts mehr
da können wir mit unseren evolutionären
denkapparat nur noch wahrscheinlichkeit
feststellen da widerspricht sagen die
quanten realität unserer unserem
normalen denken könnten wir sagen ja das
wäre ein argument also die revolution
die wirklichkeit erschließt sich uns
nicht ganz sondern nur die wirklichkeit
die für uns evolutionär
überlebensnotwendig ist oder man könnte
sagen ja vielleicht die evolution mag
uns schon irgendwie zur wahrheit führen
aber jetzt noch nicht wir müssen noch
tausend jahre warten bis die evolution
unser denken so entwickelt hat das ist
sie selbst bekämpfen kann
es kommt relativismus rein
also ist eine problematische theorie
deswegen die wird jetzt auch bei den von
uns behandelten den kann nicht thema
thematisch aber ich wollte nur sagen so
könnte man sich das auch denken und um
diese diese einstimmung hier eben hin zu
bekommen müsste man voraussetzen dass
eigentlich denken oder begriffe können
begriffe und wirklichkeit aufeinander
bezogen sind das die wirklichkeit
begrifflich strukturiert ist das geht
ganz zurück auf parität sie erinnern
sich vielleicht diese fotografie
parmenides sagt dasselbe ist was zu
denken ist und was ist denken und zahlen
sind irgendwie dem tisch das muss
natürlich voraussetzen damit so damit
wir überhaupt erkennen können in diesem
verständnis
aber das kann man bestreiten dass die
wirklichkeit begriff ist
bei hegel und bei den idealisten die wir
noch behandelt werden wir sehen dass so
eine theorie am bier vertreten wird
soviel zur wiederholung jetzt aber
wollen wir uns noch mal ganz kurz am
augustinus zuwenden und da habe ich auch
nur ein zitat also vielleicht auch noch
mal gemeinsam lesen dass wir ganz kurz
und prägnant noch die wichtigste theorie
haben wir von ihm möchte man lesen
es geht jetzt um die frage inwieweit
können wir uns täuschen sie haben sich
nochmal es ging um die frage können wir
einen ontologischen wahrheit' begriffe
vertreten
als sie nicht nur sätze positionen wahr
oder falsch war heizwert fähig sondern
sind auch dinge war heizwert fähig und
wir hatten damals vor 23 sitzung gesagt
ja irgendwie nicht weil wir können ich
sagen der stein ist falsch oder das gold
ist falsch weil der stein ich falsch ist
und unser urteil über den stein ist
falsch und jetzt lesen vielleicht noch
mal hier
dieses zitat von augustinus werfen
möchte mal lesen sonst lese ich dann
lesen wir vor also abend durch die
aussage selbst ein täuschen der inhalt
ware inhalte nach glaubt man ihn nicht
ihm nicht zu abend in nur dadurch ware
inhalte nach dass er auch auf dass er
auf diese weise ausgesagt wird
er ist nur um absichtliche täuschung
nicht auch trug findet er aber glauben
so abend der auch die geglaubten waren
inhalten gesagt nun begreife ich dass
ein großer unterschied besteht zwischen
dem was wir aussagen und den dingen über
die wir etwas aussagen daher stimme ich
nun zu denn dies allein hinderte mich
dass alles was wir täuschung bezeichnen
als solchen bezeichnen nur dann so
bezeichnet werden darf wenn es etwas
wahres nachahmt also ich haben jetzt
plötzlich die entwickelt denn das
nachahmen wer würde denn nicht mit recht
ausgelacht wenn ein stein falsches
silber nimmt und doch in einer einstein
silbernen sagen wir das sage etwas
falsches das heißt er bringt einen
falschen inhalt vor sinn aber und planen
wir nicht ohne recht falsche silber und
jetzt kommt dieser ganz problematisch
silber weil der gegenstand selbst dieses
metall nachahmt und deshalb ist hier
nicht der inhalt unseres eine täuschung
sondern gegenstand selbst dem unsere
aussage geben jetzt noch mal ganz kurz
zur wiederholung warum kann jetzt
augoustinos so eine uns heutige doch
recht und aussiedler these vertreten
welche hintergrund annahme liegt diesem
satz dieser these zu gründen wieder
bezogen auf das verhältnis von
erkenntnis subjekt und erkenntnis ob sie
so kann er sagen
zinn und blei tauschen uns darin dass
sie vorgeben
silber zu sagen ja
genau das war eine ganz seltsame
auffassung der dinge also da wird ein
ding fast schon eine aktivität eine
intention könnte man sagen sind absicht
unterstellt dass wir würden auch wieder
sein das absurde dinge haben überhaupt
keine absicht dinge sind völlig neutral
dinge werden von uns interpretiert das
sind alles projektionen könnte man sagen
projektionen in die dinge hinein was
könnte man jetzt sagen ja
also sie verweisen auf einen größeren
kontext innerhalb dessen der stein und
das objekt steht und ich glaube das geht
in die richtige richtung zahlten sie
sich erst sie glauben
so könnte man das interpretieren dies
ist eine meldung gewesen
richtig also urteil oder denken und
seilen hängen sehr eng zusammen das geht
wieder hier in diese richtung denken und
wirklichkeit in dieser korrespondenz
theorie aber ein punkt haben jetzt noch
nicht genannt denen wir das letzte mal
herausgearbeitet hatten denken sie noch
mal das verhältnis von dingen im kontext
der subjektivität die dieses ding kennt
wie ist das verhältnis von erkenntnis
publik und objekten der welt geschaffen
und das ist ganz wichtig auch vor dem
hintergrund von descartes den wir jetzt
heute auch noch lesen wollen jetzt
nämlich grundverschieden von dem
katholischen verständnis der welt und
der wirklichkeit also man könnte doch
jetzt sagen die dinge werden
gewissermaßen fast schon personifiziert
bei augustinus und einging eine sache
uns täuscht also man könnte auch sagen
die in wirklichkeit und subjekt stehen
in einem engen zusammenhang
sie sind sich nicht kategorisch
verschieden sondern sie beziehen sich
auf den gemeinsamen kontext und diese
gemeinsame kontext den hatten wir das
letzte mal theologisch genannt also
alles wie in einem zweck verhältnis die
dinge sind dazu da damit sie etwas tun
also dinge liegen nicht einfach nur vor
der herum deskriptiv sondern man könnte
sagen seine schwache normativität eine
schwache zwecksetzungen schwach sollen
die dinge sollen etwas
es sollen etwas sie sind nicht in
different uns gegenüber seinen dinge
können uns wahrheit verschaffen sie
können uns zur wahrheit verhelfen aber
sie können uns genauso gut auch in
diesem wahrheit' verhältnis stören als
es eine viel engere zusammenhang von
wirklichkeit und subjekt das subjekt ist
aus der wirklichkeit nicht so heraus
reflektiert wie wir es gleich beide
karten werden deswegen finde ich hier
diesen satz sehr zeichnend für dieses
mittelalterliche verständnis wo auch
denken und sein urteilen und seien sehr
eng miteinander zusammen
hängen gewissermaßen eine uhr
vertrautheit von subjekt und ein
erkennbarer wirklichkeit die deswegen
auch täuschung genannt werden kann die
vom ding ausgeht könnte man sagen oder
ja könnte man sagen aber ich denke also
durchaus es ist auf den menschen bezogen
also der mensch täuscht sich nicht so
das ding täuschte menschen
das könnte man so nennen ja ich würde es
eher theologisch nennen dass man es sagt
weil weil es geht auch nicht nur um den
menschen jetzt in diesem bild sind der
mensch und die die steine sind teile
eines kosmos eine ordnung eines eines
geschaffenen kontextes der aufeinander
abgestimmt ist und da steht der mensch
gar nicht mehr so sehr im zentrum sollen
die dinge bekommen eine sprache schon
fast das ist ein bisschen über ein
bisschen überspitzt gesagt aber so ein
satz nein weil der gegenstand selbst
dieses metall nachahmt das ist für uns
heutige doch schwer zu verstehen
entropa zentrische ok als andere prozent
des antriebs der mensch und zentrum dass
der mittelpunkt dass der mensch sich ins
zentrum stellt von allem unter prozent
trägt der mensch ist das maß aller dinge
gibt es gibt es auch den spruch zur
festen der mensch ist das maß aller
dinge der dinge der seine das ist oder
nicht sei das nicht sind der mensch ist
alles an sich und die integration des
kommilitonen bat die dass man wohl wenn
ich sie recht verstand habe dass man
dass der mensch von sich aus dinge
hinein projiziert in die dinge habe ich
sie der recht verstand das also von sich
aus denen seine intention in die steine
hineinlegt könnte man so nennen
ich würde es eher theologischen weil man
von einem wie gesagt von einem kontext
ausgeht wo der mensch nicht nicht zu
trennen ist von den dingen wo der mensch
mit den dingen ihre beziehungen tritt
und sich gar nicht dass er herausnimmt
dieses andere prozent rische oder
subjekt zentrische sich ihr bei techart
die er sich selbst von der welt
verabschiedet gewissermaßen sich heraus
reflektiert und dann dreht sich alles
nur noch um ihn selbst während hier
dreht sich sie auch so ein bisschen um
die dinge natürlich kann man sagen gut
dreht sich um die dinge weil der mensch
seine intention in die dinge vielleicht
hineingelegt hat nach unserem heutigen
verständnis aber die zum setting es geht
also das ist auch noch wie es geht nicht
um das setting also es geht nicht nur um
das verhältnis von objekt und subjekt
erkenntnis wirklichkeit und erkenntnis
erkenntnisse blick sondern es geht um
den rahmen innerhalb dessen sich diese
relation von a und b befinden und diese
rahmenbedingungen die wechseln ständig
die wechseln also durch alle der hier zu
lesen texte durch die relation bleibt
dieselbe häufig in relation zur b
erkenntnis subjekt verhältnis zur
erkenntnis wirklichkeit das muss
irgendwie korrespondenz seien aber in
welchem kontext das geschieht ob wir ein
theologisches setting haben ob wir ein
idealistisches setting
wie es bei hegel dann der fall ist ob
wir ein objektives tisches setting haben
wie das prädikat gleich sehen wird das
ändert sich also wenn sie dann mal eine
hausarbeit schreiben
achten sie immer auch darauf wie das
setting ist der kontext welche zusatz
prämissen die häufig unausgesprochen
bleiben mit eingehen und diese wahrheit
juni
es finden sich ganz viele struktur
analogien dazwischen zum beispiel jetzt
auch wenn sie sagen wenn man sagt die
korrespondenz theorie dass das
erkenntnis objekt der wirklichkeit
angemessen ist
diese korrespondenz theorie wird in
einem idealistischen setting indem man
sagt die wirklichkeit ist schon
begrifflich strukturiert plötzlich zu
einer karenz theorie weil dann geht es
ja darum dass ein begriffe also unser
begriff und der begriff der wirklichkeit
als die wirklichkeit ist auch
begrifflich zutritt dass die nicht nur
übereinstimmen weil übereinstimmung tun
sie ja immer schon apriori sind das die
logisch logisch korrespondiere logisch
kurrent sich fügen also man kann sagen
wenn man eine korrespondenz theorie sehr
idealistisch denkt kommt man am ende
vielleicht bei einer und theologischen
kohärenz theorie heraus wo dann
plötzlich kohärenz theorie theorie nicht
mehr das problem haben dass sie mit der
wirklichkeit nichts zu tun haben dass
sie darüber so schweben das hat mir
gesagt das problem der normalen corinths
theorie sowohl plötzlich diese fügung
diese logische fügung selbst
wirklichkeit verbirgt oder produziert
wie auch immer also wir sehen es gibt es
gibt da durchaus übergänge je nach
setting von korrespondenzen corinths
theorie aber behalten sie immer diese
settings im hintergrund die sind ganz
wichtig für diese bestimmungen das noch
mal dazu jetzt im eilschritt nochmal zu
anselm von canterbury denen wir auch
kurz hatten und der etwas verwirrend war
und wir wollen ja aber auch nur ein
einsatz lesen 1 in von canterbury ist
der erste der ein traktat nur der
wahrheit gewidmet hat und wir lesen
jetzt noch ein zitat und wollen es nur
ganz kurz fragen welche wahrheit'
theorie hier zugrunde liegt
möchte mal jemand von ihnen lesen bitte
lesen sie einfach beides
vielen dank
also das ist glaube ich jetzt ziemlich
einfach hier kann man schon erkennen
welche wahrheit' theorie anselm vertritt
korrespondenz kohärenz was würde ich
sagen ja genau
und hier sogar ziemlich modern
anmutender man muss natürlich jetzt auch
immer ins lateinische hineingehen
schauen was sachverhalt ist proposition
oder wie auch immer also ganz klar wie
sich der sachverhalt tatsächlich verhält
die aussage stimmt mit der wirklichkeit
überein
wir haben jetzt wie das problem wie sich
der sachverhalt auch tatsächlich verhält
schmuggelt er sich hier nicht in dieses
tatsächlich das hinein war sie gerade
bestimmen möchte oder sucht die wahrheit
in dem wir sagen tatsächlich setzen wir
gerade die wahl wieder voraus
ja das ist so das problem was ich hier
sehe
die aussagen
[Musik]
genau als es geht jetzt nicht darum
wirklich herauszufinden mit bestimmten
mitteln was jetzt war es oder nicht man
setzt jetzt einfach mal voraus es wäre
möglich ein sachverhalt ganz klar zu
bestimmen
und dann muss das urteil mit diesem
sachverhalt übereinstimmen das problem
ist jetzt eher logischer natur wie
gesagt nicht erkenntnistheoretische
logischer haben wir nicht eigentlich da
in diesen tatsächlich in diesen begriff
tatsächlich schon das prädikat enthalten
und müssen wir wieder fragen hier aber
wie kommen wir denn zum tatsächlichen
hindern müsste man wieder sagen ja
tatsächlich ist die beinstellung unseres
denkens mit der wirklichkeit mit der
tatsache als mann kommt aus diesem aus
dieser tatsachenbasis gar nicht heraus
aber das wollte man doch gerade
herausfinden
mir scheint das ganze ein bisschen
zirkuliert zu sein so wahrheit zu
bestimmen und planung hat es gesehen und
hat deswegen so scheint mir bleiben hat
das gesehen hat deswegen noch die idee
des guten da eingeführt über allem
schwebt aber auch das ist natürlich eine
ganz starke these eine starke annahme
die man wiederum bestreiten kann
also das ist eine ganz klare
korrespondenz theorie der wahrheit und
ganz interessant hier es geht eben um
die aussage hier steht hier ist nicht
mehr so sehr von dingen die rede wie bei
augustinus sondern hier ist die aussagen
wahrheit zentralen genau also neben
diesen zwei theorien korrespondenz
theorie und kohärenz theorie unter
interessiert uns noch die frage nach dem
wahrheit träger nach der frage ob setzte
nur wahr sein können begriffe oder
präpositionen oder nicht auch dinge und
wir haben jetzt mit augustinus ein
vertreter der ontologischen wahrheit'
theorie gehabt
das ist jetzt aber eine position aale
wahrheit' theorie könnte man sagen die
nur auf aussagen auf proposition trifft
ja
richtig völlig richtig
das ist eine sehr gute beobachtung man
könnte das sagen bis jetzt geht s haben
wir es mit einem war als theoretischen
optimismus zu tun
die wirklichkeit die lässt sich
prinzipiell erkennen
mehr noch die wirklichkeit die kann uns
sogar die wirklichkeit täuscht uns und
nicht wir uns also nicht wir sind schuld
zu sagen haben extremfall sind die
wirklichkeit ist schuld ist
es ist ein sehr großer optimismus ins
spiel der wieder mit diesem setting
zusammenhängt
alles ist wohl gefühlt alles ist
technologisch in einem verhältnis und
dieses dieser optimismus könnte man
sagen wie auch immer dieses dieses unter
logische verständnis theologische
verständnis dieser relation erkenntnis
subjekt zur wirklichkeit die frage ist
das technologisch also zweckmäßig sind
die beiden eher zweckmäßig aufeinander
abgestimmt dieses technologische
verhältnis wird mit descartes auf dem
wir jetzt gleich kommt nachdem wir
thomas von aquin noch gelesen haben
zerstört gewissermaßen also für die card
gibt es dieses technologische verhältnis
nicht mehr die welt in fremde wir
entfremden uns von der welt die welt
entfremdet sich von uns welt und
erkenntnis objekt stehen sich getrennt
besteht eine kluft zwischen beiden und
für die karte geht es nur noch darum zu
zeigen wie wir diese kluft überwinden
als die dinge sprechen nicht mehr mit
uns die dinge sind tot die dinge sind
nicht nur tot sind obskur wir haben
schleier vor uns und müssen mit ganz
geschickten tricks müssen wir versuchen
diesen schleier weckt ziehen
wir müssen einen ganz klaren blick
wieder auf die dinge bekommen das hat
schon fast etwas mechanisches denken sie
an die damalige zeit euch will es nicht
zuviel vorwegnehmen
denken sie an die erfindung des
mikroskops denken sie an die ganzen
optiken optiker dieser zeit linsen
schleifer
werkzeugmacher erfinder die zeigen uns
wie wir mit geschickten mitteln unseren
wahrheit hin zu schärfen können dass wir
wieder diesen von vornherein
problematischen zugang zu den dingen
herstellen können er geht sehr viel von
uns aus aber darauf komme jetzt noch nur
als kontrast verwendung also hier wie
sie aussagen wahrheit und korrespondenz
und jetzt komme so thomas von aquin und
jetzt geht es hier wieder wenn sie den
titel sich anschauen um quest juni ist
also fragestellungen über die wahrheit
will jemand von ihnen lesen sonst ließ
ich wenn es freiwillig gibt können sie
gerne vor sonst lesen ich mal was nicht
miteinander identisch ist unterscheidet
sich irgendwie voneinander war es und
sein dass aber unterscheiden sich in
keiner weise voneinander denn sind es
scheint sich nicht durch die wesenheit
da jedes sein die durch seine wesenheit
ein wahres ist sind erscheinen sich auch
nicht durch irgendwelche art
unterschiede
dann müssten sie in einer gemeinsamen
gattung übereinkommen also sind sie ganz
und gar dasselbe wenn sie nicht ganz und
gar dasselbe sind
es war es etwas zu sein dem hinzufügen
wahres fügt aber seitdem nichts hinzu da
sich sogar weiter erstreckt als sein
dass dieser hält durch den philosophen
aristoteles dem vierten buch peter wick
sagt wir definieren was wahres ist gehen
wir sagen was ist ist oder was nicht ist
ist nicht und somit schließt war es sein
dass und nicht sein dass ein allzu fügt
wahres zu sein denn nichts nicht etwas
hinzu und somit scheint war es ganz und
gar dasselbe zu sein wie sein dass
dagegen eine tautologie ist die unnütze
wiederhole und dasselbe wäre also war es
dasselbe wie sein das wäre es eine
tautologie von wahrem seinem zu sprechen
das ist jedoch falsch also sind sie
nicht der
so also um was geht es in diesem
disputation des platzes geht also immer
thesen und den hebel gibt es gegen
hilfen dagegen die solistische methoden
immer eine these eine partei und wird
eine gegenthese eingenommen oder
versucht man zu einer synthese gewesen
meint kommt man versucht durch diese
geologische geschehen dialektisch nennt
sich dass die dialektik die kunst des
argumentieren hingegen setzten denken
seiner wahrheit zu einer erkenntnis zu
kommen so also wie die frage steht im
zentrum diesem abschnitt
ja genau
genau wie stehen wahrheit und sein teilt
oder existenz dass das wahre das sein
dass sein das waren wir stehen die ein
verhältnis zueinander und es gibt
mehrere möglichkeiten sie können
identisch mit länder sein
und sie können es nicht sein
genau als wir das ist dass diese
disputes dieser disputation stil der
gehört er hat gewisse ist euch sagen
schlangen bewegung der der ist nicht
ganz klar zu übersehen erst mal wohin
das führt aber jetzt hatten sie gesagt
erscheint dafür zu argumentieren dass
sie also zumindest in dieser these die
gegenthese sagt ja jetzt gerade
es sollte nicht dasselbe sein dagegen
was ist jetzt also fragen wir mal so was
spricht dafür dass wahres und sein dass
identisch sind
nach diesem text ist
warum könnte bei der meinung sein sein
und wahrheit sind
genau ist genau wie kann man sich das
vorstellen
also wie kann man sich das vorstellen
dass wahres dem seine etwas hinzufügt
könnte sich jetzt überlegen eine wahre
aussage über einen sachverhalt oder wenn
ich einen sachverhalt als sachverhalt
erkenne dass das jetzt wahres silber ist
dann fügt die erkenntnis dass dieses
silber war ist dem ding nicht hinzu es
ist dasselbe silber das betrifft nur das
verhältnis zu uns
ich denke es geht in diese richtung also
wenn wir wahrheit erkennen und wenn
wahrheit stattfindet dann kommt darin
dass sein der sache ganz zur geltung in
ihrem sein dass sein zeigt sich uns die
sache zeigt sich uns gewissermaßen aber
das ganze zeilen sein wenn man so
sprechen kann seinen kontexten das zeigt
sich uns nur es erschließt sich uns und
das ist dann die wahrheit letztendlich
und in dem es sich zeigt kommt ja nichts
hinzu sa ist bleibt gerade dasjenige was
es ist
ja aber da ist schon eine meldung da
hinten
aber ich denke sie haben da schon den
richtigen punkt getroffen also man kann
sich nur die frage ist ob etwas wenn es
nicht identisch ist dem ein was
hinzufügen muss ne das ist die frage
hier war kann sich schon vor ständig den
keinen grund der dafür spricht beide
irgendwie als ähnlich oder identisch
anzusehen ist der dass ein wahres immer
sich nach dem seinen richtet es ist es
nur in bezug auf das eint auf die
wirklichkeit möglich und denken sie mal
wahrheit von der korrespondenz theorie
hier heißt nur übereinstimmung also
wahrheit ist der effekt der
übereinstimmung von erkenntnissen
wirklichkeit und übereinstimmung heißt
eigentlich nur es ist derselbe extension
ist derselbe science bereich also das
urteil was dann so wahrheit führt was
war sein kann dass umreißt gerade diesen
science bereich ist definiert ihn gerade
und damit tut es ihm nichts hin zu essen
es bleibt gerade in seinen grenzen um
diesem in seinen grenzen bleiben zeigt
die wahrheit
also diese adäquat zu könnte man sagen
der wahrheit' theorie die bedeutet
gerade dass es genau sich nach dem
seinen richtet und dann nichts
hinzufügen ist gerade repräsentiert
richtig definieren könnte man sagen oder
es geht darum dass uns etwas als war
erscheint und wahrheit wäre dann dass
der schein seien sich eben als sein
zeigt das schein und sein irgendwie
übereinstimmende dann hat man wieder
dieses problem der korrespondenz da ist
noch die meldung
ich rate dazu ja
und ich denke das ist oder was nicht ist
ist nicht und somit war es zeit ist und
nicht sein dass ein letzter schluss
fußball ist ja man könnte ja auch oder
ist da gerade eine meinung dazu
die war sein können
genau dann also wahre aussagen über
dinge die nicht existieren medea
existiert nicht in dieser welt dann
betrifft und so könnte man es verstehen
dass ich wahrheit auch auf sachverhalte
richtet als auch ein sachverhalt könnte
auch sein dass etwas nicht der fall ist
genau das ist auch eine spannende frage
die wir hatten das war glaube ich bei
augustinus gewesen dieses medea beispiel
nicht wahr das nicht da mit diesem wagen
diesem himmels wagen
das ist ein riesenproblem wie verhält es
sich mit nicht existierenden dingen ich
meine es kann ja sein da ist blei und
das scheint uns nur so als ob es silber
seite hamada was aber wie verhält es
sich mit fiktionalen objekt mit
fingierten dingen die gar kein science
zu konstanten
ja
genau das ist eine gute frage wie kann
man das verstehen
und das geht gar nicht also es ist
skiurlaub schließt bau zu sagen was es
nicht ist das ein problem ist sie haben
sich noch dazu gemeldet zu der frage
ja
gerade als das muss man im hinterkopf
haben thomas will jetzt hier noch nicht
gleich auf eine kommission hinaus sind
erwägt erstmal verschiedene auffassungen
ab das heißt wir müssen erstmal noch
weiter lesen wie wie genau dieses
verhältnis zu bestimmen ist sie haben
die nochmalige
wollen sie ist gerade noch einmal das
hatten wir kurz wollen hatte ja bitte
genau dann stellt sich die frage wie es
mit fiktionalen objekten zb hamlet oder
superman wenn wir über die reden wenn
ich jetzt sage superman wiegt 80
kilogramm
wie verhält es sich mit diesem urteil
dieses urteil kann gar nicht mit der
wirklichkeit überein stimmen oder nicht
weil es gibt keine referenz
es gibt keine möglichkeit dass dieses
urteil abweichen kann
weil es gibt nichts von dem es abweichen
kann es gibt dieses objekt nicht
also das ist auch ein problem mit diesen
auf möglichen hinweisen also das ist
dieses medea beispiel bei augustinus nur
fiktionale objekte und wirkliche objekte
die wir falsch beurteilen oder die uns
täuschen im augustin ischen setting das
möchte ich muss man auch dazu sagen was
ich noch hier erwähnen möchte ist diesen
ersten satz
da jedes seite durch seine wesenheit ein
wahres ist das ist glaube ich
nachvollziehbar also wir können das
seien die eben erkennen und dann hier
sie unterscheiden sich auch nicht durch
irgendwelche art unterschiede
dann müssten sie einen gemeinsamen
gattung über ein kommt darauf mich noch
ganz kurz zu sprechen kommt was ist was
liegt diesen gedanken zu grunde dass sie
sich nicht durch art unterschiede
voneinander differenzieren sie müssten
eine gemeinsame radtour über ein
ja genau
genau also arten und gattungen also wenn
etwas art genannt wird der muss es eine
gattung geben und dieses feld und
vielleicht werden sich noch wir hatten
einmal diesen begriff der
transzendentalen hier verwendet
transzendentalen sind gerade diese
letzten gattungen könnte man vielleicht
sagen oder letzten begriffe die nicht
mehr unter eine übergeordnete gattung
gebracht werden können das war das eine
designer die trends and a liehen um
währung wohnung das gute ist auch noch
eine transzendentale das kann man sich
fragen ob das gute wirklich was ist es
sind praktisch die letzten begriffe und
insofern sie die letzten begriffe sind
könnte man sagen dass sie dass sie
letztendlich einerseits sich
unterscheiden voneinander weil sie eben
nicht mehr aufeinander zurückgeführt
werden können
das ist ein punkt dass sie verschieden
sind die letzten begriffe die letzten
strukturen der wirklichkeit aber in dem
es eben die letzten begriffe sind nehmen
sie sagen die grenze der wirklichkeit
und den horizont so vielleicht dass das
wenige was ist angeben sind sie gerade
wieder identisch das ist diese spannung
sind die letzten nicht mehr aufeinander
reduzierbare begriffe aber es sind die
letzten
insofern bezeichnen sie denselben
horizont sie definieren denselben
horizont dass es diese spannung glaube
ich von dem es um die es hier jetzt geht
indieser diesem diesen text werde ich
dann gleich weiter
ja ok genau ist die gattung wäre die
gattung wäre transzendentalen und darin
sind sie identisch insofern sitrans
zentralen sind aber sie sind eben an
verstrichen arten der fälle von
exemplifiziert von trans zentralen aber
er ist gut dass sie immer auf diese
widersprüche hinweisen dass sie
hinweisen wenn es hier probleme gibt wir
lesen mal weiter dass es vielleicht zu
klein das können sie es lesen wollen sie
es lesen sondern lesen ich mal vor jede
erkenntnis aber vollzieht sich durch
eine anpassung und jetzt kommt ein ganz
in trun zitat durch eine anpassung des
erkennenden anders erkannte ding jetzt
leuchten bei ihnen die alarmglocken oder
auch nicht und zwar derart dass die
besagte anpassung ursache der erkenntnis
ist der gesicht sind beispielsweise
erkennt eine farbe dadurch der sinn
einen derart dieser farbe gemäßen
zustand gerät das erste verhältnis des
seinen zum verstand besteht also darin
dass sein dass unverstand
zusammenstimmen welche zusammen stimmung
angleichung des verstandes und des
dinges genannt wird und darin von
vollendet sich der sinngehalt von wahres
dies also ist es was wahres zu sein dass
hinzufügt aha jetzt gibt es doch ein
hinzufügung die gleichförmigkeit oder
angleichung eines dinges und des
verstandes dieser gleichförmigkeit folgt
wie gesagt die erkenntnis des dinges so
also geht die zeit heilt eines dinges
dem sinngehalt von wahrheit voraus muss
es heißen die erkenntnis aber ist eine
gewisse wirkung der wahrheit
demgemäß findet man das wahrheit oder
wahres auf dreifache art definiert
werden erstens gemäß dem was dem
sinngehalt von wahrheit voraus geht und
worauf wahres grundgelegt ist so
definiert augustinus im buch allein
gespräche zurückwies
haben wir gelesen war es ist das was ist
und david senn am 11 buck der metaphysik
die wahrheit jedweden dinges ist die
eigenart seines seins welche sind
dauerhaft eignet und ein gewisser
autoren so das wahre ist die ungeteilte
von sein und dessen was ist zweitens
definiert gemäß dem worin der sinn
gehalt von wahres seine vollendete form
erreicht und so sagt isaak wahrheit ist
die angleichung eines dinges und des
verstandes und anselm im hoch von der
wahrheit wahrheit ist die recht haid die
nur durch den geist erfasst werden kann
von dieser recht hat ist nämlich im
sinne einer gewissen angleichung geredet
und der philosoph augustinus sagt im
vierten buch der metaphysik wir
definieren das wahre den wir sagen wenn
man sagt was ist ist oder was nicht ist
ist nicht drittens wird das wahre
definiert gemäß der im folgenden wirkung
und so sagte marius war es zeigt sein an
und macht es augenscheinlich und
augustinus im buch von der wahre
religion wahrheit ist wodurch sich das
zeigt was ist und in dem selben buch
wahrheit ist dass demgemäß wir über die
niederen dinge urteilen
das haben wir also ganz viele wahrheit
definitionen jetzt noch mal zurück
gefragt welche wahrheit theorie vertritt
thomas hier auch wenn er sich immer
wieder auf die tradition bezieht ist
eigentlich ziemlich klar
ja
genau ja sie hatten sich noch gemeldet
genau auf sie haben sich noch gewählt
wollten sie auch sagen
gut gute bemerkung also er könnte jetzt
sagen
es findet ein bisschen anthropozän
tourismusstadt oder subjekt centris muss
also es geht jetzt plötzlich hier mehr
vielleicht könnte man sagen um das
erkennen des objekt- und die
wirklichkeit steht uns gegenüber und wir
können uns hier besser oder schlechter
annähern und bei augustinus ist es so
dass von der aktivität ausgeht oder dass
eben dieser doppelpfeil berücksichtigt
werden muss ist jetzt noch einfacher
geht es anfang denken zur wirklichkeit
und ich zurückstehen ich meine
wechselverhältnis vielleicht einem
aktiven wechselverhältnis oder
vielleicht cassano teleologischen könnte
man sagen haben sie sonst noch hier
andere bestimmung der wahrheit es gibt
hier noch ein paar weitere feinheiten
die man achten muss wenn sie jetzt mal
schauen wie genau bestimmt er jetzt die
anpassung dass die ersten zeilen dieses
textes
oder anders gefragt warum sagte jetzt
hier das war es zu sein dass etwas
hinzufügt
weil die frage also wie verfügt das
wahre dem seinen etwas hinzu
als könnte man sagen wahrheit ist eine
art effekt ein effekt der erzielt wird
in dem bezug genommen wird auf ein sein
dass das ende ist immer dasselbe
aber es ist ein effekt ein effekt in
relation zum sein denn lobt sie das so
sehen
und deswegen ist etwas mehr als das sein
oder nicht etwas deswegen tut es etwas
hinzu
würden sie das so aussehen
ja sie haben sich doch gut oder
ach so ja
das ist eine gute bemerken und diese
machen weil hier immer jetzt von den
dingen die rede ist
also man hat jetzt eine vorstellung als
ob es jetzt in diesem juli diesen blei
beispiel zu bleiben es gibt ein dinge in
der welt und wir beziehen uns auf dieses
ding das ding ist ein objekt aber jetzt
haben sie gibt einen anderen fall
gebracht wenn jetzt etwas passiert ein
ereignis oder ein prozess ein prozess
ist kein ding wenn wir jetzt sagen
personal hat person b beleidigt ist es
kein ding
es kann aber der war der fall sein oder
nicht das ist ein sachverhalt
es geht um einen sachverhalt nicht mein
ding deswegen sprechen viele heutzutage
nicht mehr von einer ding wahrheit so
von einem sachverhalt zu erhalten also
es geht an sachverhalt dass da liegt
jetzt bei hier oder silber dann mache
ich daraus nicht dass silber dass beides
erlebt sondern dass hier auf dem tisch
silber liegt der sachverhalt dass da was
liegt wir formulieren dass um die ding
wahrheit in eine position aale wahrheit
und dann können wir eben auch ereignisse
prozesse oder sonstige dinge sage jetzt
mal plötzlich in seine war heizwert
fähige form bringen
also wir reden nicht mehr unter logisch
ist das ding ist war der sachverhalt und
die proposition die meinung dass da
jetzt silber auf dem tisch liegen und
transformiert diese dinge onkologie in
eine tatsachen und theologie der
proposition aale und theologie ja bitte
genauso müsste man das verstehen genauer
seine tatsache also bestehende
sachverhalte das ist das seien ja also
interessant ist jetzt hier wie gesagt
dass er sagt immer die anpassung dass
der gesicht sind jetzt kommt die
analogie beispielsweise erkennt eine
farbe dadurch dass er in dieser art ein
grad dieser farbe gemäßen zustand gerät
soll das heißen gesicht sind wird auch
nicht grün wenn ich grün erkennen dass
die frage wie kann man dass diese diesen
gemäßen zustanden
das ist also dritte zeile hier diesen
die tat hier gemäß zustand gerät
genau diese keiner genau
gerade das problem der farb erkenntnis
ist ein riesenthema
die frage ist ja wirklich erkennen wir
farben wirklich so wie sie an sich sind
diesen fragen was erkennen wir
eigentlich wenn wir jetzt etwas als grün
erkennen oder war's jetzt hier
was ist das substrat was ist die
struktur die der grund dafür ist dass
das weiß ist es ist ja nicht so dass
jetzt da weil es irgendwie sich bewegt
oder so sind sind
oberflächeneigenschaften sind
oberflächeneigenschaften die das licht
auf eine gewisse weise reflektieren
physikalische eigenschaften
mikroskopische eigenschaften die dann am
ende gar nichts mehr wenn ich mich nicht
täusche mit der qualität war es zu tun
haben wenn wir den grund dafür angeben
dass etwas rot erscheint oder rot ist
dann kommen wir auf micro physikalische
strukturen die phänomenal nichts nur mit
rot zu tun haben das sind irgendwelche
mikrostrukturen und das heißt
phänomenale eigenschaften aber auch also
beim geschmack ist es noch mal anders
und beim geruch beim geruch ist es ja so
dass sich kleinste moleküle lösen von
gegenständen und in unserer nase
eindringen und an dem riechkolben das
ist ja der vorderste teil des gehirns da
andocken und dafür dann wirklich ein und
logischer austausch statt also da haben
wir wirklich die molekulare struktur
sagen gerochen also das ist dann
wirklich ein unmittelbarer bezug zum
sein wenn die moleküle in uns bei
unseren song andocken
aber auch da kann man sich fragen ja gut
da haben wir halt eine molekülstruktur
aber das ist doch nicht der geruch aber
es ist ein engeres verhältnis als mit
der farbe also die frage ist hier
wirklich wie man dieses an gleich und
diesen gemäßen zustand sich vorstellen
kann
hier scheint so erscheint gemeint sein
dass hier so eine struktur analogie
getroffen
aristoteles macht das ganz anders
aristoteles sagt es geht immer um formen
erkenntnis immer erkenntnis von formen
es geht um die ecke wenn ich den tisch
erkenne erkenne ich ihnen dadurch dass
ich seine form erkennen dass ich seine
form aufnehmen
und er sagt unser verstand hat den
charakter der form hat inform charakter
und die dinge der welt haben auch vom
charakter und in dem beide formen
charakter haben können sie in einem
verhältnis zueinander kommen weil sie in
der struktur analogie haben sie sind
beide form haft gestaltet der verstand
ist eine form und die dingen der welt
haben ihre form und die verstandes form
nimmt die formen der welt irgendwie auf
so kann man sich das erklären ist beides
formen
hier muss man sich fragen wie genau
jetzt dieser gemäße zustand verstanden
werden muss wie auch die angleichung zu
verstehen ist
es gibt es hier ebenso ein paar weitere
bestimmungen ich würde sagen wir gehen
noch mal weiter ich lese mir vielleicht
ein bisschen hier wir überspringen
bisschen was mal schauen vielleicht kann
man das hier lesen
ich sehe es auch noch mal ganz kurz vor
also ein bisschen länger vielleicht ein
bisschen schwierig zu lesen ich nie
zuvor zum ersten einwand ist also zu
sagen jene definition des augustinus
betrifft die wahrheit in sofern diese
eine grundlage im ding hat und bezieht
sich nicht darauf dass sich der sinn
gehaltes waren in der angleichung des
dinges an den verstand vollendet oder
wenn es heißt war es ist das was ist
dann ist das zweite ist hier nicht
aufgefasst insofern es ein akt des seins
bezeichnet sondern insofern als zeichen
des zusammengesetzten verstandes ist
nämlich insofern es die behauptung eines
satzes bezeichnet somit ist der sinn war
es ist das was ist nämlich wert von
etwas das ist sagt das ist so dass die
definition des augustinus auf dasselbe
hinausläuft wie die oben angeführte des
philosophen zum dritten etwas ohne ein
anderes verstehen kann zweifach
aufgefasst werden erstens man versteht
etwas während man das andere nicht auch
versteht entsprechend verhält sich was
begrifflich voneinander verschieden ist
so zueinander dass das eine ohne das
andere verstanden werden kann zweitens
dass etwas ohne ein anderes verstanden
wird kann man so auffassen dass eine
wird verstanden während ist das andere
werden ist das andere nicht gibt auf
diese weise kann man sein dass nicht
ohne wahres verstehen denn sein das kann
nicht verstanden werden ohne dass es mit
dem verstand zusammen stimmt oder ihm
angeglichen ist es ist dennoch nicht
notwendig dass jeder wird den sinngehalt
von sein das versteht auch den von war
es versteht wie ja auch nicht jeder der
sein das versteht den tätigen verstand
versteht wohl ohne den tätigen verstand
nichts verstanden werden kann
zum 6 wahres und sein dass unterscheiden
sich begrifflich dadurch dass im begriff
das waren etwas enthalten ist das nicht
in dem das zahlen enthalten ist nicht
aber derart dass im begriff des seines
etwas enthalten wäre das nicht dem
wahren enthalten wären daher gibt es
keinen wesens unterschied zwischen ihnen
und sie sind auch nicht aufgrund einer
entgegengesetzte art unterschiede
voneinander
verschieden das ist das was wir jetzt
von midgard schon mit dem trans
zentralen hatten zum siebten war es
erstreckt sich nicht weiter als sein
dass sein das ist einer gewissen weise
in einer seines einer gewissen weise
aufgefasst wird nämlich auch vom nicht
zeichnen gesagt insofern nicht sein es
vom vorstand erkannt wird daher sagt der
philosoph aristoteles im vierten buch
der metric das verneinung oder
mangelndes seinen in einer gewissen
weise sein dass genannt wird
aus demselben grund sagt auch wiesen am
anfang seiner metaphysik des lasse sich
eine aussage nur etwas sein das bilden
weil der subjekte aussage von verstand
erkannt sein muss woraus offenkundig ist
dass jedes waren gewisser weise sein das
ist zum ersten gegen einwand der
ausdruck war es sein das ist keine
tautologie und zwar deswegen nicht weil
durch das votum war es etwas ausgedrückt
wird das durch sein dass nicht
ausgedrückt wird nicht aber deswegen bei
wahres und seines der wirklichkeit nach
verschieden wäre ja hat macht ihn das
ein bisschen den vorherigen zitate
klarer also war es uns sein das sind in
einer ganz ganz komplizierten beziehung
zueinander
es gibt einerseits gründe die annehmen
lassen dass sie irgendwie sehr sehr
verwandt sind dass sie die mit
deckungsgleich sind weil war es ja
nichts den psalmen hinzufügt wie wir
gesagt hatten andererseits haben wir
gute argumente bares und seines zu
trennen weil man könnte zum beispiel so
argumentieren nach heutiger sicht weil
bares nämlich immer ein ästhetisches
verhältnis zum sein denn mit dem spiel
bringen haben das wäre zum beispiel eine
aspekte sagt nach heutiger sicht waren
seine sind deswegen nicht dasselbe weil
der brief der wahrheit vielleicht nicht
erst hinein und theologischer begriff
ist der die dinge betrifft sind wir
immer unser verhältnis zu den dingen
betrifft also mit könnte sagen wahrheit
ist noch eine reflexion stufe über dem
sein denn es ist etwas was sich auf das
zahlen die immer schon bezieht
deswegen ist es nicht auf derselben
ebene vielleicht angesiedelt so könnte
man
[Musik]
sicherlich sicherlich ja so könnte man
es sehen ja wobei thomas immer noch
wahrheit und theologischer versteht als
wir heutzutage also heutzutage ist für
uns wahrheit oder frage meint sie alle
wo würden sie sagen welcher
philosophischen disziplin oder wohl
überhaupt wird der wahrheit' begriff
zentral welche disziplin speziell mal
oder sagen sie mir allgemein in welcher
wissenschaft und wie im bereich des
lebens würde man sich heute noch auf den
begriff der wahrheit beziehen und der
physik
würde sagen
wichtig ok in diesem sinne die richtige
diagnose aber würde jetzt nicht im
strengen sinne von wahrheit sprechen
also der begriff der warten wir können
sagen ist es richtiges angemessen es ist
korrekt es ist plausibel es ist sinnvoll
aber jetzt mal ganz im strengsten sinne
von wahrheit welche disziplin spricht
man noch von wahrheit ja vielleicht ja
rechtswissenschaften ja immer wieder
seien indizien
es gibt indizien an indizienbeweis und
dann spricht von beweisen vielleicht
also ich denke es ist schon ihr mit der
wahrheit denken sie noch einen schritt
weiter wo gibt es noch wo es der
wahlbrief noch zentral aber
rechtswissenschaften ist schon gut ja ja
ja wobei ist natürlich sehr
problematisch ist heute sagen dann hat
etwas verschiedene religionen die alle
ihre wahrheit haben aber auch da wird
der begriff der wahrheit eine rolle
spielt wo spielte den objektiv und
völlig neutral und völlig emotionslos
eine rolle
ja ja genau mathematik oder logik logik
und sagt wir definieren wahrheit in der
methodik der wahrheit oder identität
meta logische operationen da ist diese
völlig völlig neutral keine emotionen
spielen rolle
das ist eine spannende frage genau weil
das ist eine spannende frage weil wir
würden heutzutage sagen also wir
modernen sage jetzt mal
wir würden sagen wahrheit ist ein
logischer begriff logik ist aber nicht
und theologie logik betrifft strukturen
verhältnisse von gedanken
das hat jetzt nichts mit der welt wie
sie wirklich zu tun sind formale systeme
corrente systeme oder man würde sagen in
wahrheit betrifft unser verhältnis als
erkenntnis objekt zur welt dann ist
wahrheit ist aebischer begriff bis
technologie erkenntnistheorie würden
aber heutzutage eher weniger die these
vertreten dass wahrheit ein
theologischer begriff ist in dem sinne
dass er in der welt sich vorfindet und
thomas ist ihren und hat dann er unter
logische wahrheit theorie
obwohl ich ihnen auch zustimmen also
wahrheit er hat immer etwas von effekt
heftigkeit wahrheit liegt in den dingen
nicht um weit hängt mein ding schon
zusammen in sofern sie als war erkannt
werden können
die dinge sind so im theologischen
kontext mit uns verwoben dass sie
prinzipiell erkennbar sind das ist
dieser optimistische hintergrund dieses
setting so dass sie die augustinus sagt
uns auch täuschen können aber dennoch
scheint wahrheit auch bei thomas etwas
mehr zu sein weil es eben ein effekt der
erkenntnis ist über das sein der als
eine reflexion auf das was ist
wichtig und da setzte eben voraus dass
also dass diese möglichkeit erkenntnis
ist in diesem theologischen kontext
eigentlich nie unstrittig also es gibt
natürlich falschheit auch aber das
überhaupt wahrheit möglich ist es gibt
ja moderne theorie die sagen und auch
relativistische theorien wahrheit ist
ein konstrukt
denken sie an friedrich nietzsche
willkommen auf ihnen wahrheit ist eine
reine überlebensstrategie wahrheit ist
ein machtmittel der begriff der wahrheit
ist ein machtmittel der von
interessensgemeinschaften geprägt wird
die wahrheit gibt so ähnlich weit gibt
es natürlich wenn man das sagt die
wahrheit gibt es wenig dann behauptet
man ja gerade etwas als wahr und kann
man sich fragen begibt man sich nicht in
performative widerspruch der wahrheit
ist es immer so eine sache
dann können wir überhaupt denken ohne
wahrheit' ansprüche zu erheben also
können wir überhaupt reflektieren ohne
etwas als war anzunehmen auch wenn wir
annehmen dass es keine wahrheit gibt
eine spannende frage
aber hier ist jedenfalls ein größerer
erkenntnis optimismus der sich diesem
ontologischen theologischen setting
verdankt ja
genau das wird wieder zu den
transzendentalen nun um das eine währung
das wäre um das wahre bonum das gute das
sind die und ernst als dass eine dass
die letzten kategorien die sondern sich
nicht mehr aufeinander reduzieren lassen
und die insofern gewissermaßen
austauschbar sind es gibt diesen spruch
ohne und währung conwert und uhr die
lassen sich austauschen
sie sind damit nicht identisch aber sie
bezeichnet die letzten grenzen unseres
trans zentralen unseres horizontes in
dem sich überhaupt etwas ereignen kann
[Musik]
ja also ich denke auch das gute bei
pumas ist er in diesem sinn zu verstehen
die bei platon die idee des guten
also sie sagten ja völlig zu recht dass
währung oder das einzuzahlende um das
gute spielen eine ganz zentrale rolle
und als tanz enttarnen und das müssen
wir aber eher von platon er verstehen
denken die idee des guten die idee des
guten das ist jetzt ich glaube wert
theorie wäre noch ein bisschen zu eng
gefasst das wäre eher modernere begriff
des bonus ist hier wirklich aller
weitesten sinne als als objekt auf dem
dass wir uns vielleicht will endlich
beziehen können aber das steht natürlich
auch eine normativität drin dass etwas
einen sinn hat das etwas letztendlich
das etwas überhaupt erkennbar ist
das ist die theologische struktur die es
in diesem bonum trimmen das ist diese
gefügt hat dieser optimismus und das
geht eben descartes verloren also dieses
wohnung würde die tat bestreiten also
keine wohnung mehr in der welt
hier ist
theologie war hier in diesem
genau in dem dem ersten zitat hatten wir
genau hatten wir diese technologie
ich habe also vielen dank für den
hinweis das ist ein wichtiger punkt hier
haben wir in diesem ersten zitat hier
unten dagegen dagegen eine tautologie
ist die unnötige wiederholung desselben
wäre als wahres dasselbe wie es sein das
wäre es eine tautologie von wahren
zahlen zu sprechen
das ist jedoch falsch sind sie nicht
dass
genauso taut es führt irgendwas hinzu da
ist kein beitrag genau ist jemand disput
als er führt verschiedene thesen an und
gegen tiefen also es ist nicht immer
seine meinung als er
also unum und währung sind oder dass das
das wahre unter sein das sind trans cent
arien sind als die letzten grund
bestimmung der welt und in dieser trans
and a liad zeigt sich eine spannung
steigt die spannung da sie einerseits
und dent oder ähnlich sind sehr alt
aufeinander angewiesen weil sie eben
nicht mehr weiter reduziert werden
können sie die letzten horizonte diese
als letzte gattung letzte arten wie auch
immer darin sind sie einige sie sind
austauschbar einer gewissen weise
sie betreffen den letzten horizont aber
sie sind jetzt nicht synonym sie lassen
sich nicht begrifflich auto logisch
aufeinander reduzieren das ist eine
spannung in denen sich diese letzten
arten befinden das ist denke ich der
hintergrund und einer ein weiterer grund
dafür ist der dass thomas sich eben die
welt mich so vorstellt wie wir sie uns
heute denken dass wir das erkenntnis
subjekt haben das zum objekt steht und
dass wahrheit nur in der funktion der
erkenntnis liegt also wahrheit tritt auf
wenn wir eine übereinstimmung herstellen
sondern wahrheit ist immer schon der
ganze hintergrund in dem sich etwas
vollzieht also wahrheit ist
gewissermaßen der rahmen die wahrheit'
fähigkeit von allem also wahrheit wird
hier im mittelalterlich technologisch
sehr sehr ökologisch gedacht und nicht
nur des theologischen auch nicht nur
logisch also wahrheit ist etwas was
prinzipiell fähig ist möglich ist und
nichts etwas dem er auf die spur kommen
müssen erst mal als wir sind immer schon
im wahren könnte man auch sagen
nach diesem verständnis sind immer schon
im seinen immer schon waren die dinge
zeigen sich uns manchmal auch nicht aber
prinzipiell schon während bei descartes
auf den wir jetzt gleich kommen werden
wie eben nicht immer schon waren sind da
ist ein grundmisstrauen programm weite
card und er würde also deswegen auch
dieser trans and arlen lehre
widersprechen dass man unter logisch von
dem wahren sprechen kann
er würde es sagen wahrheiten wir kommen
jetzt gleich darauf zu sprechen ist
immer nur etwas was ich im beziehung von
erkenntnis objekt zur erkenntnis objekt
vollzieht jetzt lesen wir vielleicht
noch rest kurz durch obwohl der amazon
halbe stunde
ich schaue mal gerade hier das
vielleicht noch also dagegen ist wieder
eine gegenthese der philosoph
aristoteles sagt im sechsten buch der
metaphysik falsches und wahres ist nicht
in den dingen sondern im geist wahrheit
ist angleichung eines dinges und des
verstandes
diese angleichung kann aber nur ein
verstand sein also ist auch wahrheit nur
im verstand das ist die frage wo ist die
wahrheit
antwort etwas von vielen dingen gemäss
eine ordnung des früheren und späteren
ausgesagt es muss nicht demjenigen
zuerst zugesprochen werden welche sich
zu den anderen wie eine ursache verhält
sind diejenigen in welchem erster linie
der sinngehalt sind gehalt jenes
allgemeinen vollständig enthalten ist so
wird gesund zuerst zum singen wesen dem
an erster stelle der sinngehalt von
gesundheit vollendet zu finden ist
ausgesagt dieses so obwohl eine medizin
gesund wird gesund genannt wird weil sie
das die gesundheit bewirken de ist
deshalb muss wahres da es gemäss einer
ordnung von mehreren ausgesagt wird von
jenem zuerst ausgesagt werden in dem
sich in erster linie der vollständige
sinngehalt von wahrheit finden und liegt
aber die vollendung
die entweder bewegung oder tätigkeit in
deren entziehen die bewegung der
erkenntnis kraft aber endet in der seele
denn das erkannte muss im erkennen
entsprechende art des erkennenden sein
bewegung der strebe kraft jedoch endet
in einem ding daher behauptet der
philosoph im dritten buch von der seele
einen gewissen kreis laufenden
tätigkeiten der seele ein ding das
außerhalb der seele ist bewegt nämlich
den verstand
das erkannte ding wiederum bewegt das
strebe vermögen unter strebe vermögen
ist darauf aus zu den dingen zu gelangen
von welchem die bewegung ihren
ausgegangen haben weil nun das gute wie
gesagt wurde in ordnung des zahlenden
zum strebe vermögen das sagt das war
aber in ordnung zum verstand sagt der
philosoph im sechsten buch der meter
sieg gutes und schlechtes sein in den
dingen wahres und falsches aber in der
seele ein ding aber wird war genannt nur
insofern es den verstand angeglichen ist
deswegen deshalb findet sich war es in
den dingen später zuerst aber ich
verstand
ja also ja
und hier haben wir jetzt wieder diese
spannung auch zwischen wahrheit und sein
wenn sie mal schauen jede letztes hat
deshalb findet sich war ist in den
dingen es findet sich eine dingen aber
erst später zuerst aber im verstand
also man könnte sagen hier kommt wieder
durch die wahrheit etwas hinzu es macht
das ganze verschieden wahrheit uns sein
aber jetzt nicht wesentlich wesenhaft
sondereffekt haft oder logisch gesehen
könnte man sagen eine logische
unterscheidung es geht um eine logische
priorität
es geht nicht um eine definitorischen
wesens bestimmung sondern es geht um die
logische ordnung blick auf unser
erkennen was aber immer schon ein teil
der wirklichkeit ist das ist das setting
in dem thomas jetzt endlich sich
befindet und dieses setting wollen wir
jetzt im hinterkopf behalten wenn wir
weiter gehen auf die nächsten denke
nämlich descartes und wenn sie jetzt mal
schauen wie es sein
sein werk hier genannt wird es sind die
regeln zur lenkung des verstandes ja die
regeln kombination ist private also wie
könnte man das übersetzen haben sie eine
idee soll man es selbst gespräche nennen
ja private gedanken könnte man
vielleicht wieder selbstgespräche wie
bei augustinus wie auch immer die karten
einer gewissen einem gewissen bezug zu
augustinus auch dieses sogenannte
korrektur argument ich denke also bin
ich denke ich bin das findet sich schon
bei augustinus das ist so neu gar nicht
wir wollen jetzt in die wir wollen jetzt
in diesem seminar nicht die meditation
von descartes lesen sie kennen diese
meditation wurde karl sich überlegt was
kann
erkennen was kann denn überhaupt
erkennen was kann erkannt werden haben
sie idee bei descartes wissen sie dass
sie wirklich aus einem anderen
hintergrund war es ist nach descartes
absolut zweifelsohne und täuschung
resistent ja das ist die richtige
richtung er sagt es noch ein bisschen
spezifischer es sagt nicht nur verstand
sondern ja genau das denken ist
natürlich hat eine verstandes tätigkeit
das denken und es ist nicht nur
irgendein denken sondern es ist das
denken ja genau also das denken genau
das denken des subjekts dieser
privilegierten zugang zum eigenen
mentalen wirklichkeit und die karte geht
ja sogar soweit er sagt nicht nur denken
also denken ist der paradefall aber er
sagt auch noch das wollen das empfinden
selbst solche dinge also letztendlich
rudimentär durch subjektivität
begleitete akte in immer subjektive akte
die geben uns die gewissheit die nicht
mehr täuschung anfällig ist also dass
ich auch jetzt gerade etwas will das ist
vielleicht auch so eine form der
zweifelsohne existenz weise
und wenn sie jetzt mal von diesem
setting wieder von diesen
rahmenbedingungen ausgehen was fällt
ihnen auf die meditationen descartes
fragt ganz zu beginn dass die
überschrift glaubt der ersten meditation
oder zweiten die lautet woran alles
gezweifelt werden kann
das ist so diese überschrift nur
angezweifelt werden kann
ja das ist doch mal ein völlig anderes
setting als bei thomas und bereits
behandelten oder
ganz genau
guter punkt genau also die karte geht so
weiter sagt es könnte sogar so weit sein
dass du für einen bösen geist einen
genius malikis erschaffen wurden dass
wir uns in mathematischen wahrheit
enttäuschen
also dass zwei und zwei nicht gleich 45
darin könnten wir getäuscht werden
stellen sie mir das vor normalerweise
würde auch die mathematik immer als die
parade-disziplin letztendlich für
wahrheit einsichtigkeit gebracht und er
geht so weiter wie kann man sich das
vorstellen dass wir in zwei und zwei
gleich vier getäuscht werden
man kann sich das so vorstellen dass
vielleicht die evolutionstheorie nach
modernen begriffen uns einfach defekt
erschaffen hat uns mit bestimmten
begrenzung produziert hat man könnte
sich es auch so vorstellen ganz normal
dass dieser teuscher dämon uns
manipuliert indem er zwischen uns und
die welt tritt also es geht hier um das
verhältnis von wieder es geht
letztendlich auch bei descartes wieder
um eine attraktion
es geht um das verhältnis von subjekt in
wirklichkeit auch hier haben wir wieder
die selbe relation von der korrespondenz
theorie nur die wieder einem anderen
setting und das setting ist jetzt beide
karten ganz stark subjekt bezogen und
die wirklichkeit ist nicht mehr
technologisch prädikat nicht mehr ganz
und gar nicht und die kluft zwischen
wirklichkeit und subjekt ist extrem also
extrem fast schon eine unüberwindbare
kluft könnte man sagen und tatsächlich
ist sie unüberwindbar
weil die katja zu seiner gewissheit
nicht dadurch kommt das irgendwie auf
die welt bezug nimmt sondern er macht er
folgendes er nimmt auf sich selbst
bezogen hier also dieser teil der wird
auch erst mal gestrichen
wenn die relation wird außer in relation
zur b wenn jetzt babywelt wird wird
jetzt endlich in relation zu wenn man es
war so möchte wenn man das überhaupt so
sagen kann also das subjekt das bezieht
sich auf sich selbst und so eine
selbstreflexive tät die verbirgt
plötzlich die wahrheit die gewissheit
als es ist praktisch eine korrespondenz
des objekts mit sich selbst könnte man
sagen korrespondenz theorie ist nicht
mehr subjekten mit wirklichkeit songs
objekt mit sich selbst
letztendlich schon letztendlich schon
genau also ganz am ende kommt er dann
von meditation macht einen gottesbeweis
ökologischen gottesbeweis und also wenn
der card jetzt darauf zu sprechen kommen
möchte dann ist es glaube ich wirklich
wie sie sagen dann hat er sein
gottesbeweis und gott ist allmächtig all
gültig er muss daher dafür sorge tragen
das objekt und wirklichkeit irgendwie in
einer korrespondenz möglichen
korrespondenz relation sind genau das
ist so wie die idee des guten bei platon
völlig richtig diese diese idee stiftet
diese möglichkeit der korrespondenz aber
bis er überhaupt dahin kommt muss er
eine ganz seltsame operation vornehmen
nämlich dieses selbstbewusstseins
theorie also eine korrespondenz des
objekts mit sich selbst
hier fällt die welt seite völlig weg
eine besonderheit und gelangt man zum
schluss dass ist sage ich jetzt noch
kurz vorweg das eben all das wahr ist
was ich klar und deutlich erkennen klare
instinkte erkennen also hier haben wir
so eine art evidenz kriterium und wir
wollen jetzt mal schauen wie descartes
dieses kriterium genau erfasst als wir
brauchen jetzt jedenfalls nach dem kart
um zu den dingen selbst zu kommen
methoden die dinge entziehen sich uns
die welt ist prinzipiell zweifels
anfällig auch dass er mit dem zweifel
beginnt wieder thema täuschung täuschung
zweifel bei augustinus hatten wir die
täuschung schon sehr zentral die card
ist eine tradition
er denkt die täuschung so zentral er
spricht eigentlich fast gar nicht er
spricht vielmehr von täuschung vielmehr
von falschheit als von wahrheit
das zeigt schon sehr viel zeit schon
sehr viel aus über dieses
weltverständnis dieses setting
es geht also darum dass august als
descartes letztendlich instrumente
findet hier das habe ich bei
instrumentale instrument
das verhältnis von subjekt und
möglichkeit wird nicht mehr
technologisch gedacht so ein instrument
ell
welche instrumente muss sich dazwischen
schieben hier um zur wirklichkeit zu
kommen ich muss der wirklichkeit her
werden indem ich sie ganz geschickt
angehe
ich muss irgendwelche hilfsmittel
sekunde nehmen auch methoden ich brauche
dieser bezug ist nicht mehr unmittelbar
da muss jetzt plötzlich etwas getan
werden
im gegensatz zu thomas von einträgen im
mittelalter
also das verhältnis wahrheit' verhältnis
wird problematisch und jetzt wollen wir
schauen wie genau wird jetzt die
wahrheit gewonnen also wahrheit muss ich
gewissermaßen erarbeitet werden
die wahrheit muss muss mühsam gewonnen
werden
und da bringt jetzt die charts ein paar
regeln also eine methodologie wie wir
der wahrheit wieder auf die spur nachdem
dieses verhältnis nicht mehr so
selbstverständlich theologisch geordnet
ist ja diesmal vor die sterblichen sind
von einer so blinden neugier besessen
dass sie ihre geisteskraft oft
unbekannte wege einschlagen lassen nicht
etwa weil ihre hoffnung irgendeinem
grund hätte so nur auf den bloßen
verdacht hin dass dort vielleicht das
herumliegt und auch sie fragen wie
jemand der ein so unbändiges verlangen
hat eine geldbörse zu finden dass er
ständig die straßen auf und ab geht auf
der suche nun vielleicht eine zu finden
die ein passant verloren hat so
studieren fast alle chemikern die
meisten geometrischer und nicht wenige
philosophen ich bestreite gar nicht mal
dass diese leute gelegentlich so
glücklich ihren dass sie auch etwas
wahres treffen also was ist die kritik
an der gemeinen wissenschaft die die
karte gibt
genau also um eine geldbörse zu finden
wäre es in dieser analogie diesem
beispiel schlecht immer nur die straßen
entlang zu laufen
was müsste man machen man müsste ja man
müsste sich um im bild zu bleiben über
erstmal überlegen ja wo ist denn die
wahrscheinlichkeit am größten dass
geldbörse verloren werden
dann würde man nicht irgendwelche
straßen entlang laufen sondern würde
natürlich nur solche straßen laufen wo
besonders viele personen sind und so
weiter und so fort ist diese analogie
die hilft nicht sehr viel weiter gehen
würde müsste sich etwas dabei denken
also das ist praktisch der punkt es gibt
keine methode ist einfach willkürlich
ist völlig beliebig und deswegen auch
nicht erfolgversprechend aber ich gebe
deswegen noch nicht zu dass sie
fleißiger sind so nur dass sie mehr
glück haben gleichwohl ist es viel
besser jemals auch nur daran zu denken
nach der wahrheit irgendeines dinges zu
fragen als dies ohne methode zu tun also
das ist der leitsatz für descartes und
darin sehen sie den extrem unterschied
zu allen bisher behandelten themen
wahrheit und methode hängen unmittelbar
untrennbar miteinander zusammen
keine wahrheit ohne methode wahrheit
ohne methode wäre nur glück glück wäre
willkür wäre etwas was nicht meiner
freiheit meiner zurechenbarkeit sich
verdammt diskutieren gleiche arbeit gehe
es erstmal zu ende ist es nämlich ganz
gewiss dass durch solche ungeordnete
studien und dunkle meditationen das
natürliche licht in unordnung gebracht
und die geistes kräfte geblendet werden
und alle die es sich angewöhnen so in
der finsternis herumzugehen schwächen
die schärfe ihre augen so sehr dass ich
danach nicht mehr im offenen tages nicht
aufhalten können
das bestätigt auch die erfahrung denn
wir sehen sehr oft dass diejenigen die
sich niemals der bücher gelehrsamkeit
verschrieben haben sehr viel
verletzlicher und klare über vorliegende
dinge urteil als diejenigen die sich
immerzu an der universität
herumgetrieben haben und einer methode
verstehe ich sicheren einfach regeln die
jeden dass sie genau befolgt niemals
falsch ist als war voraussetzen lassen
und ihn weil er die anstrengung des
geistes nicht unnütz aufwendet sein
wissen stets schritt weiß vergrößert zu
wahren erkenntnis all dessen gelangen
lassen wozu er fähig sein wird da stehen
jetzt sehr viel interessante punkte drin
die eigentlich das ganze anliegen von
descartes in seinem verhältnis zur
wahrheit auf den begriff krieg bringen
ja was was entnehmen sie diesem zitat
mit blick auf unsere frage wie bei die
karte zwar heizöl subjekt zusammenhängen
auch jetzt vielleicht wieder im kontrast
zu den mittelalterlichen theorie
also oder anders gefragt welche welche
charakteristika müssen methoden haben um
wahrheit generieren zu sein
wollten sie gerade dazu etwas sagen oder
sagen sie ruhig zu dem was sie sagen
ja und wie muss diese methode sein sagt
haben sie da auch schon was entnommen
aus die wie diese methode genau sein
muss einfach das ist wichtig und da ist
eine kritik gegenüber den universitäten
hier also also einfachheit führt zum
ziel also man braucht nicht super
kompliziert zu sein
es muss dann nicht an universitäten sein
sonst kann jeder letztendlich nennen
sonst noch was implizit einfachheit ja
sondern wir sammeln hier sammeln wir mal
wie soll ich es nennen
sagen sie mir also wie muss die methode
sein simple regeln ja ja
ja woran machen sie das fest ok genau
also kritische kritische haltung ja ok
kritische haltung ja ja das ist auch gut
genau die schrittweise das steckt
eigentlich schon der methode drin
methode kritische methode ist der weg
also die methode ist letztendlich schon
dass hier nicht dass uns vorgibt wie wir
das zu machen hat eine methode erfolgt
immer schrittweise
haben wir ist in diesem text schon was
davon die rede wenn man könnte
sicherlich seinen prinzipien oder so
prinzipien die frage wäre ja auch
erstmal wie kann ich die prinzipien
erkennen
aber ganz ohne prinzipien kann ich
natürlich nicht beginnen wobei methode
jetzt er sehr formal ist methode ist ja
noch nicht jetzt inhaltlich irgendwie
bestimmt als methode wir jetzt einfach
nur strukturen formen des denkens ganz
allgemein simple regeln es muss impel
seit ich unterstreiche simpel einfach
schritt weiß auch wichtig was noch gibt
es jedoch was
sicher sichere und einfach simple regeln
sichere regel sicher was heißt sicher
sicher die frage ist natürlich ist im
begriff der sicherheit nicht schon
irgendwie zirkuliert auto logisch der
begriff der wahrheit enthalten
das problem geld wenn man sagt sich ja
sie sie für den erfolg ja aber sie
sollen doch gerade zum erfolg führen
genauso ich so schon verfahren ein
verfahren auch noch verfahren fahren ja
es hat etwas falsch ein automatisches
noevers das wär's fast schon
mechanisches das hat was von apparatur
ökonomin ökonomie das ist auch mit
diesem simplen schon enthalten ökonomie
ökonomie ja ja ja
fokussiert ein fokus ja genau
genau das ist auch noch gut und jetzt
hier was mir noch aufgefallen ist er
spricht hier von einem licht der
vernunft
er spricht er hat hier wieder eine
visuell als visuelle metaphern
er spricht von finsternis augen dass mit
dem tageslicht nicht aushalten können
hier das ist fast wie platon sehen sich
das höhlengleichnis also ihr müssen
jetzt genau schauen wieder welche rolle
hier das natürliche licht das natürliche
licht das ist die evidenz also das was
uns ein leuchter und das ist jetzt schon
wieder eigentlich so eine große tour
vertrauen als würden sie das eigentlich
kein technologischer kontext mehr und
das natürliche licht zeigt dass die
karte ist für prinzipiell doch irgendwie
möglich hält dass wir dass sich die
natur die wirklichkeit uns erschließt
aber das ist eben sehr stark von der
subjekt seite außer nicht von der für
eine wirklichkeit seite her
das ist natürlich auch der metaphorische
nebel müssen wir sagen also natürliches
licht ist eine reine metapher darf man
jetzt nicht so viel davon ab lesen aber
es führt wiederum trotz aller skepsis
sondern also ansicht eines prinzipiellen
urvertrauen
genau das ist dieses glaube menon im
dialog mähne und ist das glaube ich
dieses dieses dilemma der erkenntnis wir
müssen doch eigentlich immer schon mit
diesen dingen vertraut sein plan löst
dieses problem auf dass wir etwas
erkennen sie müssen ja immer schon
wissen müssen was es ist dass wir
erkennen wollen plattform löst dieses
problem dadurch auf dass es sagt wir
erinnern uns nur wieder also erkenntnis
eines dinges ist nicht erkenntnis etwas
ganz fremden etwas ganz anderen weil
dazu hätten wir prinzipiell nie die
möglichkeit bezug herzustellen wenn
erkenntnis bedeutet etwas für uns ganz
verschiedenes zu erkennen kann man sich
fragen wie kann ich denn zu diesem ganz
verschiedenen um es zu erkennen
überhaupt erstmal bezug auf zudem wenn
es doch mir völlig fremd ist werde ich
doch nie damit den bezug kommen sagt da
tun
ich glaube es ist im dialog der grund
dafür ist der dass wir eigentlich nichts
fremdes erkennen wenn wir erkennen
sondern nur etwas wieder erkennen was
wir schon mal erkannt hatten und platt
und sagt dann das ist jetzt endlich die
annahmen es dieses wiedererkennen wieder
erinnern der ideen der dinge die wir vor
unserer geburt geschaut haben waren also
vor unserer geburt in diesen ideen
himmel haben alle ideen gesehen und in
dem wir geboren wurden haben wir sie
vergessen
wir können uns durch methodische
sokratische my magic da haben wir
eigentlich auch schon die methode bei
platon damals nicht auch die methode
schon können wir uns wieder erinnern als
auch bei platon kommt eigentlich schon
so eine methode ins spiel aber völlig
anders als bei den karten also für in
einem anderen setting aber auch bei
platin spielt methode eine rolle
gefunden
ja also es liegt doch durchaus auch ein
gewisser trotz aller skepsis gewisser
erkenntnis optimismus immer noch zu
kunde also deshalb das prinzipiell
können sich uns die dinge zeigen aber
der entscheidende unterschied ist jetzt
der es hängt ganz entscheidend von uns
ab von unserer freiheit ist nämlich auch
noch so ein punkt den man spielen muss
von unserer freiheit ob wir die
prinzipiell erkennbare wirklichkeit auch
erkennen können
das ist nehmen wir müssen die
hilfsmittel die zu richtungen die
vorrichtungen aufbringen um uns um
dorthin zu gelangen und das ist etwas
was dieser stärke bei niemandem davor zu
der fall ist
es hat durchaus platonische züge
ich lese dass noch vor der messe
schlüssel und auf zweierlei ist hierbei
zu achten selbstverständlich nichts
falsches als war vorauszusetzen und zur
erkenntnis von allem zu gelangen
denn wenn uns von all dem was wir wissen
können irgendetwas unbekannt bleibt dann
nur deshalb weil es uns entweder niemals
irgendeinen weg aufgefallen ist der uns
zu einer solchen erkenntnis geführt
hätte oder weil wir den
entgegengesetzten wird schon begangen
haben wenn aber die methode richtig
erklärt wie die intuition des geistes
verwendet werden muss damit wir keinen
irrtum begehen mit dem wahren
entgegengesetzt ist und wie die
reduktionen herausgefunden werden können
damit wir zur kenntnis von einem
gelangen dann scheint mir alles
vorhanden das sein was die methode
vollständig macht denn wie vorher
bereits gesagt lässt sich wissen nur
durch intuition des geistes oder die
reduktion erlangen denn die methode
lässt sich darüber hinaus nicht auch
noch darauf aus denen zu leeren
wie diese operationen selbst angestellt
werden müssen weil sie die schlechthin
einfachsten erstens sind deshalb würde
unser verstand sie nicht vorher schon
verwenden könnte noch nicht einmal die
einfachsten vorschriften methoden selbst
verstehen die anderen operationen des
geistes hingegen die die dialektik zur
unterstützung dieser beiden ersten bei
stellen können
so können behauptet sind hier ohne oder
müssen sogar zu den hindernissen gezählt
werden weil man zu dem reinen licht der
vernunft nichts hin zum zug kommt kann
was es nicht in irgendeiner weise trüben
würde ganz entscheidend jetzt also wir
haben uns noch ein punkt wir haben noch
die optionen der dotation reduktion ist
praktisch die logische ableitung aus
prämissen die gehalts waren die
ableitung des nicht empirisch sind wir
wie bei wir schließen aus prämissen
logisch auf eine konklusion also
detektiv und ich sind nicht induktiv
rein logischen bleiben
das ist noch wichtig und jetzt 1 letzter
1 letzte bemerkte dazu als praktisch
eigentlich fast alle charakteristika dir
jetzt hier aufgezählt hat weil er jetzt
es sagt hier was die methode vollständig
macht das heißt er hat hier mit der
methode vollständig beschrieben
er spricht jetzt hier es sein die
einfachsten vorschriften die schlechthin
einfachsten erst die operation
es heißt man könnte sagen es geht auch
descartes und transzendentalen und die
letzten grundbegriffe die jetzt aber
nicht in der welt liegen sondern denken
selbst in der operation weise des
subjekts den verlagert könnte man sagen
die trans zentralen in das erkennen des
ug ist also meine thesen aber darüber
kommen in der nächsten sitzung weiter
reden in der wir uns noch mal ein
bisschen medica beschäftigen werden und
in der wir auch noch kurz auf leibnitz
zu sprechen bis dann